Last year my company's did over $250,000
in aggregate revenue. I've been in
business for over a decade and a half.
Uh in this video, I'll show you how we
use AI to make our business better,
cheaper, faster, and less risky for our
customers. I'll also walk you through
some real examples of every department.
Number one, how do we actually make the
business better? So, if we think about
each of the functions of the business,
you're going to be turning raw attention
into some sort of profit. Right? Like if
we look at businesses that are to
manufacturing about. And the first, I
think, misconception that people have
around implementing AI into their
business is they think they must become
an AI business, which is not true at
all. And so, the easiest analogy I can
give is the internet. Right? So, almost
every business is on the internet. You
don't have to be an internet business,
you just use the internet as one of the
many tools that you use to deliver
whatever it is that you sell. And so, I
think the first mistake that I'm seeing
businesses make is assuming that either
they have to become tech companies. Now,
there's a component of being tech
forward, uh but like are you tech
forward for having web page? Not
anymore, but you used to be. And the
people who got there first got
disproportionate returns. The second
kind of big thing that is being a
mistake is assuming that like one of the
tech nerds is going to do it for you.
Now, one of the the big advantages of
the thing that I've had that's that's
led to some disproportionate outcomes
for me has been what I'll consider cloud
to dirt knowledge. So, like vertical
integration of knowledge. So, being able
to do the high-level strategy, being
able to handle the people stuff,
communication, marketing, all the way
down to the granularity of like how do
we connect this API to this other API.
And the reason I think that cloud to
dirt understanding of all systems within
the business is valuable is because
you're the only one who's going to
understand what is possible. So, even if
you have some tech nerd, right, who's
next to you, you would then ask them,
"Well, what is possible?" And they're
going to answer within their limited
context of business. And so, if you know
your business better than them, which
you should if you're the owner, then you
can see how different pieces, if applied
together, would be really valuable. They
won't see that inherent value, and so
they're going to default to things that
they've seen before um that people have
done, which largely will be what I would
consider commoditized automations,
right? And so, where you get the true
alpha or the true kind of big
improvements in the business are going
to become come from your business acumen
getting overlaid on top of technical
acumen. Now, you probably don't consider
yourself to be a tech person. I
certainly don't. In fact, I would say
that I I don't even like saying it, but
I largely dislike technology. Um but I
see it as a necessary evil, being, you
know, emphasis on the necessary part,
which is that you've got to get good at
this So, I'm going to give you a
couple of things that you can do, and
then I'll give you some examples of the
stuff we've done. But, things that you
can do today right now is there's a
zillion videos on YouTube on how to
automate a specific thing or task within
a business. They exist, you can find
them on your own time.
What I would encourage you to do is take
the link, take the transcript, and then
say, "Hey, I want help building this
thing." And then plug that into whatever
AI you want,
and then follow the directions. And when
you get stuck, take a screenshot of the
page and say, "What do I do now?" and
put it in the chat. And do that over and
over and over again. So, from marketing
perspective, um we have an AI SDR right
now who's who's matching our our human
team. Okay. Now, one of the big mess-ups
though is that people will install
business owners will install a
half-built function of AI into their
business, compare it to something that's
been optimized over the last 6 years or
10 years or 20 years, and say, "See, it
doesn't work as well. John Henry wins
again." Right? For those of you don't
know that, well, you know, you were born
probably after 2000. Anyways. So, so the
the idea here is you have to do an
apples-to-apples comparison, which is
how long did you work on training and
putting all the SOPs together? Okay,
great. Well, then you have to apply that
same methodology to the AI. So, let me
give you a different example of this.
So, the reason that I think that like
people who have like sales called sales
AI agencies
um will struggle is that you have to
know more than just tech and just how to
sell in order to implement sales into
different businesses. And as somebody
who's been very good at acquiring
customers via checkout page, via
webinar, via in-person sales, via phone
sales,
most of the ways that you know how to
acquire customers, we've gotten pretty
good at over the years, and it's just
probably been an obsession of mine. But,
the thing is is that if I were to go
into a company and they say, "Hey, Alex,
can we use your AI setter to apply to my
whatever XYZ business?" I would say,
"Well, it's going to it's not going to
be like a simple drag and drop. It would
be like saying, 'Hey, can I take one of
your sales guys and put them in my
business?'" The first shot, you think
they're going to be good? Of course not.
They're going to suck. They're going to
be terrible, and you're going to be
like, "How is How is that good?" Now,
it's even worse if you don't even have a
very good sales process as is, and then
saying, "Oh, well, now that I have an AI
sales person or AI setter, I'm going to
run an ad and then have the AI setter,
you know, call every single person who
opts in." Well, would you have a human
call every single person that opts in?
You can then make the argument, "Well,
it'd be cheaper." It's like, "Yeah, but
would it be effective?" Most times
there's a certain amount There's a sales
motion. There's a sales process. Like AI
will make the things that you're doing
right now easier and faster. It doesn't
mean that you still don't have to do
them. Real quick, I'm going to show you
the exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to
100 million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish. I've now done multiple
times, and so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages, as
head count increases, that you need to
get through. And I broke each of these
down by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, uh service
businesses, brick and mortar, all of
this, and it works. And it's my gift to
you. It's absolutely free. And so, the
link's in the description, but you just
go acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free. So, humans
aren't going to change. Our ability to
be persuaded, the things that we find
interesting and important, those aren't
going to change. The psychology of
humans is is largely going to remain
unchanged. And so, whatever you do in
order to persuade people will still have
to happen. It's not that all of a sudden
all the rules of persuasion are broken.
And to the same degree, if your business
now starts using AI, I wouldn't
advertise that you're using AI. No one
cares. They just care that they get
their stuff faster, that they get it
cheaper, that they make it better, and
that it's risk-free. And so, let's just
hit those ones really quickly.
So, from a risk-free perspective, how
can AI reduce the risk in a business?
So, on a global level, right? Um I think
PayPal reduced its fraud uh team by a
gigantic amount, and more importantly,
they've reduced their fraud losses by
$700 million in a single year just by
having AI start recognizing patterns uh
uh faster. Now, to the same degree, on a
human savings level, uh JP Morgan had
Coin, which was their kind of like their
AI engine for, I think, like credit
agreements or something like that. But,
it basically saved like 350,000 lawyer
hours, right, which they were able to
just basically do 12,000 credit
agreements in seconds rather than having
these lawyers review them over and over
again. That is another use case. Now,
some of these seem like these big global
companies, but you're like, "How the
hell am I going to do this uh in my in
my in my small business?" Well, Clara
replaced 700 customer service agents
with AI and saved 40 million bucks in a
year. For us, when we did our book
launch, this is before people were
talking about agencies as much,
we spun up five agents that handled I
think it was like
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
120,000 support tickets. And it was
mostly just like, "Hey, can you tell me
where I get the free stuff?" Right? But,
we were able to resolve 90% of all
tickets without any human intervention.
You have to find a time, and maybe
that's weekends, maybe that's evenings,
maybe that's early mornings, maybe
that's middle of the day, whatever that
thing is for you or that time period is
for you, where you have to fully
dedicate yourself and actually go soup
to nuts, click to close, beginning to
end, on just automating one portion of
your day. That is my only ask. Now,
people have an incredibly hard time um
with this for two reasons. One, because
everyone's afraid of AI, which by the
way, if you're watching this and you
have workflows,
who do you think would be best served to
automate the workflow? Someone else or
you?
You should automate your workflow,
because then that will give you time to
figure out what else you can do that's
more valuable. Now,
every single time you think about your
workflow, whenever you want to put what
I'll just call magic or mysticism in in,
it's where you say,
"Well, I just I just kind of know or I
have a gut feeling or I have intuition
or instinct" or whatever you want to
call it, I just you to think pattern
recognition.
Because that takes all of this magic
away from it. Because you are an
organism that has been exposed to
different stimuli, and then you had
reinforcement cycles that occurred where
you realized that this, like when we
say, "Oh, I think that looks cool," it's
because we've seen things that look
similar to that. We generalize this All
right? That's how it works. And so, if
you can just erase your romanticism
around whatever niche specialized
knowledge you believe to have, and
believe me, I'm somebody who who who
thinks for a living. I would be the most
threatened by AI, right? You still have
to approach it with an observable lens,
which is what are the actual behaviors
that I do in order to get this outcome.
And so, even something as simple as
like, "Okay, I have to think of a cool
idea for this YouTube video," right?
We have different ways. I'm sure you
have some ways where you're like, "Okay,
well, I think about what I did that
week." Okay. So, could a could a bot
look at your calendar?
Okay, step one. Step two, can you record
all of the calls that you take and have
those transcribed? Okay, that's now more
interesting, cuz now I have a bot that
not only sees the calendar, it can also
know what all the conversations were.
Okay, can I then ask that bot to say,
"Hey,
any interesting situation or decision
that came up over the last week, I want
you to put the top five most interesting
ones into a document for me." And then
run it. And then great, now you've got
the five most interesting moments. What
does it also create? True stories and
narratives, which is do epic talk
about the epic you did. Right? So,
you don't have to make stuff up. The the
big the big difficulty that people will
have in the in the world of AI content
creation is proof. That's the issue.
That's the problem. And so, like there
will be amount Now, on the on the on the
consumer side,
they won't be as sensitive. On the B2B
side, abs- it still matters. Like,
imagine tomorrow
there's a B2B AI avatar, right? For
sure. Why do I think that that won't
work that well?
Because the same reason it doesn't work
for other people
who don't have any proof. The first
thing that's Like, again, human
psychology is not going to change.
People are still going to wonder, "Why
should I listen to you?
Why should I listen to this AI bot?"
Well, if that AI bot has no proof about
why it is good or what it's achieved or
what or what what real-world outcome
it's had, it's just it's just words.
It's just GPT words, right?
And so, what what then happens is like
it has to be backed by somebody who has
done some extraordinary thing. Maybe you
sold an e-commerce store. Maybe you did
uh maybe you're an amazing trader. Maybe
you're really good at real estate
investing. Maybe whatever your thing is,
right? You have to have the proof.
And so,
in a consumer world, it is easier
because and this is I mean again,
psychology doesn't change. If you have a
beautiful AI avatar talking about skin
care, people are going to see the
beautiful AI avatar, and then the way
the avatar looks
gives proof to the thing. Now, we can be
clear that obviously it's just purely
pixels and generated, but I think that
the the human psychology part, I don't
think that's going to matter.
Right? But, on the on the B2B side, I
still think it will. And so, I use all
these examples to say and hopefully
drive point a drive home a single point,
which is that
the internet is here.
It's just
you know, 25, 30 years later and it's
AI.
And
your business doesn't have to become an
AI business, but you do need to use AI
in your business. You don't need to
advertise that you use AI, just like I
don't advertise that I use the internet.
Right? I just use it. Just like you do.
And so, we use the tools to get the
outcomes. We don't advertise the tools
we use. I don't talk about my CRM. I
don't talk about, you know, what call
service we have or or you know, what
specific training I'm doing for a
specific rep. Probably not. I don't talk
about that. Cuz no one cares. They just
care about the outcome. And whether I'm
good at it is whether they buy again.
And that will come down to your skill.
And so, my big encouragement is is that
you are not too busy to do this. You
have other things that are less
important, and you need to start
prioritizing this. So, the AI equivalent
of the webpage in the internet era is is
is a different type of response because
the internet was all about connection.
And so, the website became a calling
card, right? It was a means for people
to contact. So, it was really it was it
was in some way single-faceted.
From an AI perspective,
anything a human touches
an AI can can interact with at a basic
level. And so, if we think about the
departments, right? There's going to be
AI that's going to be involved in
marketing. But, let me give you some
examples of many different ones that
small businesses use.
You can have an AI that helps you create
the ideas behind your marketing.
You can have an AI that helps you script
and package the ideas, meaning the
headlines, the thumbnails, even the
topics themselves, right? It's a little
bit kind of like the ideas. Uh
you can have AI run the tests for
different thumbnails automatically that
it generates, and then creates a skill
based on what it sees over time of
what's winning. That's on the organic
side. Now, again, you can also include
trend research there. What are the
trending formats? What are the trending
hooks? What are the trending visual
hooks, not just verbal hooks? And then
take all of that information and then
cross-reference it with past content or
subject matter that you would show your
AI that you associate with, which means
AKA brand, right? And so, you say,
"Okay, these are trending formats,
hooks, intros, visuals, and this is what
I do. Come up with the Venn diagram, the
cross-pollination of those things, and
give me 10 of those." And of those 10,
you'll pick the one you find
interesting. You click that button, and
now it starts generating the idea, the
headline, the scripts, whatever. That is
on the content side.
On the ad side, this is where it gets
very interesting, too, is that you can
create self-looking ice cream cones. Um
which means that I can make content, and
I can have the content immediately get
overlaid with a CTA, which immediately
gets put uh directly into an ad campaign
that launches every single day with
yesterday's content. You can create
endless amount of statics, static
images,
off of different data sets. So, for
example, if you run a community on
school, you could have, "Hey, I have one
tab where people list their wins."
Great. Any new win that gets added to
that immediately gets transferred over.
Um and then runs through six visual
templates that we know are high
converting. And then we will run those
as ads towards Vantage, which is our
million-dollar-plus community that we
have there, right? All of that
automated.
Pretty slick, right? And so, all of
these things like And that's again, all
of those examples are just marketing,
right? Sales, you can apply all the way
across the bat, too, which is like, "How
can I enrich the leads? How can I
respond to them quickly in terms of Can
I send an automated voice note? Can I
send um an image or text that's
obviously personalized to their
business, which we can dynamically
pull?" Yes, of course you can. Can you
do that via DM on Instagram? Yes, you
can, right? All of That's That's just on
the nurture side, right? On the
scheduling, can we do more dynamic
scheduling because we have one AI who
hands off to another AI? Yeah, is
availability less of an issue? Sure.
That means speed to contact goes through
the roof. Yes. Now, the thing is is that
we got 18 months. We have about 18
months where there's just a huge amount
of wealth that can be created by people
who have nothing.
It's a very big opportunity.
And so, no matter where you're at right
now, if you had an army of these agents
working on autonomous tasks for you,
you could get a lot more done than you
currently are.
And I think you should do that.
>> [gasps]
>> Um but I mean, it works across the
board. My legal team, you know, like I
can have one general counsel that
instead of having 100 paralegals run all
the different stuff that we have for
deals and lawsuits and whatever else
that we have going on,
she can just run it all through
different agents that have different
tasks, right? First response, second
response, cease and desist, all that
stuff that we have to do every day.